we also have a new update now from the
breaking news we're also following that
is in downtown las vegas now this one
started as a barricade in las vegas but
it ended with shots fired it happened
near 11th and bridger barco mana has
been following this story since it broke
and has new information
well denise and brian i've learned that
this barricade turned into a deadly
police shooting the crime scene tape is
still up in this neighborhood with metro
still here as well and we just heard
from metro police who say a man is now
dead after pointing a gun at officers
we're told the shooting happened near
11th street and lewis but this all
started as a barricade situation around
9 30 this morning police got reports of
someone with the gun and when they got
here a man ran into an abandoned
building metro says he was in the
doorway when he pointed his gun at
officers that's when a swat officer shot
him he died at the scene but before that
we're told the man fired his gun
randomly
while swat officers and crisis
negotiators were on scene the subjects
started to fire indiscriminately
at the surrounding area
citizens and officers were put at risk
during that time
ultimately the subject
fired appointed excuse me pointed his
weapon at officers prompting a swat
officer discharge his weapon striking
the subject
again we're told no officers and no
people in this area were injured or hurt
during the shooting and again as you
heard there from that metro officer
metro the swat officer did shoot that
man once he pointed his weapon at
officers we are still
waiting to learn a little more detail
about what exactly happened here but as
you can see some streets in the area are
still blocked off so if you're headed in
the area of maryland and carson you're
asked to avoid this area reporting live
from downtown las vegas tonight orca
mana live local now